Welcome to the Full Body IK Systems Unreal Engine Training Course.
This course is going to focus on two different IK assets within the engine, and how you would
set them both up to give your characters a Full Body IK setup that you could use to
adjust your character's pose over the top of an existing animation.
This helps with things like adhering contact points to ground planes, adjusting where a
hand might be placed when doing something like pressing a button, and anything else
where you want to adjust an existing animation to reach an IK goal.
We've included a project in the course content folder, so feel free to download that and
follow along with the demo steps as we go through the course.
We're going to take a look at what type of IK systems exist in Unreal Engine, and when
it's appropriate to use each one.
We'll then go over how to create a simple IK setup using the IK Rig asset, and then
we'll look at a more complex Full Body IK node within a control rig, showing what steps
it takes to connect the bones to the effectors, and then we'll also look at the bones settings
to see how we can adjust those to get some better results.